hello world
and welcome to my presentation it is an
amazing pleasure to be part of this very
first edition of pydera global
and it is even better to have you guys
here today as part of my audience so
thank you so for today i have a very
nice and even fun
presentation which i'm calling is a
neural network better than
a detecting team rocket and if so how
now my name is juan and i work as a data
engineer for labor
which is a dating and social application
based in germany
however for today i would like to remove
this title
and call myself a pokemon data professor
because
i'll be talking about pokemon and data
so
if you're ready follow me and i want to
start with some speaker backstory
why am i doing this what's my motivation
behind the project
and the reason is that a few months ago
i was watching pokemon
and during my journey i realized that
our dear protagonist
ash ketchum from pallet town is quite
incapable
of detecting or recognizing team rocket
under certain circumstances
and this got me thinking and i was like
hmm
could it be that a neural network is
actually better than
him at detecting team rocket and well
spoiler alert my friends
the answer is yes in most cases yes it
is and
this should not be a surprise right
because we have seen all the amazing
things that network are doing nowadays
so
for them this is a trivial case however
i want to go deeper than that and
i'm not talking about deep learning i'm
talking in the sense that i wanted to
know how
is the network actually doing this how
is the network reasoning when it see an
image of team rocket
how does it know this what does it see
and of course i want to know that if we
can explain its
answers and most importantly how can we
as the developers
or as the maintainers of this model
actually get access
to this information because i want to
see once again
so in simple words the my goal here is
to explain and to visualize the decision
that my model
is making and with that out of the way
let's jump into the agenda now after
this introduction
i'm going to present to you the context
of my problem
followed by the problem itself then the
experiment
and then the conclusion which is very
sad but of course everything comes to an
end
so the context and i want to ask you
guys what is team rocket
exactly some of you know some of you
don't that's perfect
so first of all a bit unclear i want to
say that team rocket is the main
antagonist of the pokemon world
and this theme is making of the highly
explosive jessie
super charismatic game and super funny
meow however for today i'm only going to
focus on james and jesse so
i'm sorry meow and the goal of team
rocket
for over 10 years has been to capture
pikachu
that's right this nice yellow rasp that
we have here
or this one i have here and for doing so
they employ
all sorts of techniques which includes
traps
tricks and
more tricks and the most iconic one is
disguises that's right they wear
different clothes
they try to hide themselves or pretend
to be another person
to try to trick hatch into thinking they
are someone else
and of course with the goal of capturing
pikachu
honestly they haven't been so successful
so
and this is an example of that and here
we have tim rocket wearing a nice and
pretty modern black
coat and glasses and i see them as in
rocket however ash cannot recognize it
and let's actually see an example too so
you can guys have a natural idea of what
i'm talking about
[Music]
that was really disturbing there we have
it so
what did we just watch well that was
team rocket right we were dancing waving
some flux with the big letter r
and even with that ash is like
who are these people so that's how i got
the idea
now let's jump in straight to the
problem what exactly i want to solve
for solving my problem i'm going to
split i split it into three different
parts
which is the first one of them which
takes the length of my presentation is a
neural network better than
a detecting team rocket and here i'm
going to use an object detection model
for the second part if so how i'm going
to employ a convolutional neural network
and their activation maps
and before moving on i want to quickly
say that an activation map
is the output of the layers of my
convolutional neural network
and by looking at them we can get an
idea of the most
important primary or even dominant
features of the image
and then i want to interactively
visualize the activation maps in other
words i want to build like a nice web
application with
buttons and slider where i could upload
the image
and then see the activation map and for
doing so
i'm going to use tensorflow gs because
my networks are going to withdraw
in tensorflow so for the first part
here once again i'm using an object
detection model
and the goal here is to detect jesse and
james in a frame which is an image
then i also need to mention that i train
this model using google cloud automl
which is not free but you get a hundred
free note hours which are more than
enough for training
such a small and prototype model then i
want to say that my model is an
edge model an edge here refers to a
model that is highly optimized and
capable of running on small
and simple devices like mobile devices
embedded devices and the web browser
then for the second part if so how and
here i have this network which i'm
calling
rocket.net and i run it in tensorflow
and the network is going to solve an
image classification problem
meaning that it's going to predict
whether this is jesse or
james and however as i said before
the actual goal here is to know how it
is predicting that how does it
know that it's the jesse and james and
the answer lies in the activation map
now here once again i want to
interactively visualize my activation
maps and for doing so
i'm going to use tensorflow gs and here
there are three things i need to do the
first one of them being
converting my tensorflow convolutional
network to tensorflow gs
then i need to load my google automl h
model
and then of course i need to build the
rest of the web application
sorry yeah so the experiment
so the data there's no machine learning
without data right
and my data set is fairly small it
consists of 158
images of team rocket where 87
are of jesse and 71 are of james and
even so it's
really small it should be fine because
google recommends at least using
50 images per label at the time of using
the automl
platform and even better is that when
you use how to mail
google is actually leveraging transfer
learning
so you won't train your model from
scratch which is nice so you have like
an extra
bit of help there then for the image
classifier
i'm going to augment i'm going to
increase my data set using tensorflow's
image data generator and here i want to
show you a small sample of my data set
in the top row we have jesse and below
we have
jane and the point i want to illustrate
here is that
my training set consists of only images
of steam rocket wearing their normal
white suits or outfit because
i don't want my network to see team
rocket and there are this guy
says and i actually wanted the network
to have the same thinking process as ash
and since ash is a bit bad at detecting
team rocket where they're
when they're using outfit that's what i
want the network to have to be on the
same level
as ash now this is my image data
generator
and before you start to take some
screenshots just relax
and enjoy because at the very end of the
presentation
i'm going to show you a link to my
github repo where i have all the code
here so
it's not just enjoy for now now the data
generator
and here i'm going to do several things
to augment my data set
the first one of them is rescale and
this one is going to rescale my image
when when then i have rotation range
and here with this i'm going to randomly
rotate my image
from minus 4 from minus 45 degrees up to
45 degrees
now i'm going to shift it in terms of
width
and height then i'm going to horizontal
flip it
then i'm also going to zoom in and
lastly i'm going to use 20
of these images at the validation set
now
the first smaller to do to do the object
detection one
and this model it's training google
cloud.mail
so everything you're going to see here
belongs to the google cloud console
which is full of buttons and nice blue
colors so let's begin with the first
step and the first step is to annotate
and
create my data set and here first we
need to go to the data set management
page
so on the main screen from the google
cloud console
search for data set click
and this is gonna and this will take you
to a screen that looks like this
and here first you are going to give a
name to your data set
and to select the objective which in my
case is object detection
because i want to train an object
detector
makes sense now now we need to annotate
the data set
an annotated dataset refers to the
amazing and super boring process
of drawing bounding boxes around the
target
of my training which is jesse and james
and
this is very time consuming so maybe you
should watch some pokemon in the
background while you do it
i don't know maybe you'll like it then
after that
you're going to train which is the part
we all like and love and here first we
need to define the model which means
giving a name and selecting whether you
want a cloud hosted model or edge
i want edge you click continue and then
you select the model optimization mode
and this refers to whether you want a
very fast fast fast model
which is not so accurate or a very slow
model which is a bit more accurate
i want neither of those i want the best
trade-off so i'm just going to select
the
option in the middle then pop continue
to select the node our budget and here
just
select the default value you know the
recommended one which
once again should be enough because you
have some free note hours time so
that's nice now after clicking that the
model is going to start the training
process
and it's going to take around one or two
hours so you can go out take a walk
get a glass of water and whatnot and but
beware of your phone
because once the training is done you
will receive an image from google and if
you click it you're going to see a
screen like this
and here we have the model evaluation
how did it perform during training and
during the testing phase
and in my case during testing the model
achieved appreciate a precision of a
hundred percent
great and a recall of 93.75
after that if you are happy you click
another button to put
export the model and here you have three
options
there's a flow light for mobile devices
that's pro gs for the web browser
or container in case you want to deploy
your model in a docker container in the
cloud
i'm going to select the middle one
because i want to use tensorflow
js and this is going to give you one
file
that after open it it's it's going to
contain three kind of files with the
first one of them being
model.json a model.json describes the
topology or the architecture of your
model
the next one dictionary.txt has the
labels which in this case is jesse and
james
and the last one the bin files they
represent the weights
of your model now we have the model it
is exported and i want to use it in
tensorflow gs
how am i going to do this well with
automl edge api
an automatch api is a small package that
provides you all the tools that you need
to load and to predict with your model
and here on the second statement i'm
going to use the function called
tf.automl dot load audio detection
to load my model and the only thing you
need to specify here
is the path to the location of your
model.json file
fine right then i'm going to use
model.detect to predict
and the first parameter here is my image
and the second one is an
optional object which i'm calling model
option and model options
we are going to give join to select some
attributes that you want
regarding your detection part for
example score
and score specify the minimum confidence
value
a prediction has to have to for it to be
returned
in my case it's 0.80 meaning that if the
predictions
uh confidence value is 0.79 it won't be
returned then i have top k and top k is
going to return only the
so the k the k prediction that has the
highest confidence value
in my case i only want five now
let me actually show you some of the
results here and ta-da
jesse amazing right jesse 0.93
confident if you remember the video from
before
ash was not capable of actually
detecting this so
neural network one zero but hey
what do we have here that's james
indeed that's jane well good job network
good job network two points ash zero
and guess what more correct predictions
jesse and james 0.98 0.95
and hey guess what more predictions
jesse and james
it's crazy right it's amazing i'm super
happy this model is perfect and it is
not
of course it's not the model also fails
and i realized that in cases where the
images are a bit
too goofy or too funny the model is
actually not capable of recognizing team
rocket
also we have cases like this where it's
quite hard to actually see who's here
for example i'm pretty sure that if i
would stand all the way here
and take a look at my image i'll be like
i think that's yes but i'm not so
sure about it so it's okay network i'm
going to forgive this one because it's
not a straightforward case
and then we have the awful awful cases
where i have jesse and james in the same
frame
and the network is actually not capable
of giving me both labels
just giving me one jesse and well it's
kind of right but this is jesse and
james where's james here so
yeah that's actually quite uh boring
so is another network better than a
detecting team rocket well it's a bit
better right what do you guys
think before moving on i'm sorry for
that
now i want to go to the last part of my
presentation
the image classifier and the activation
maps
and to start i want to show you the
architecture of my network and then the
code is very small
very simple it only has nine layers
which includes three convolutional
layers three max cooling layers
one flattened layers and two dense
layers with the last one giving me
the output which is jessie or james and
this is a visual
representation here we have the first
convolution
mass cooling convolution max pooling
convolution max pool intense
and dense and this is the evaluation
how did my model perform during training
and the accuracy is quite good
for both the training and the validation
set we have
0.86 and 0.80 which is great right
the same can be say about the loss value
which is also very very small
0.37 0.38
so now i have my model it's trained
it's amazing i love the results and once
again
i want to use it in tensorflow gs so i
need to convert it
and for doing so i'm going to use this
small tool called tf jf converter
and the tool is very simple to use you
only need to specify
the format of your input model which
here is keras safe model
and then the location of my model and
the location where i want to save
the model and before doing so there's
two things we need to keep in mind
and the first one of them is that
tensorflow gs supports only a limited
set of operations if you compare it to
tensorflow
meaning that you have a very complicated
or complex model
and you try to convert it chances are
that there might be one operator that is
not
yet part of the tensorflow gs api
so in this case the conversion is going
to fail
then i also want to say that you should
install this tool in a virtual
environment or in docker
because it's going to install a version
of tensorflow and this might cause
issues if you already have another
version of tensorflow
in your computer so once again limit a
set of operation and please use a
virtual
environment so now the very last part
visualizing the activation maps and the
main idea here
is to recreate my model in a way
where the outputs are going to be the
activation maps of
each of my layers and for doing so i
need to convert my model to
the sequential api to the tensorflow
functional api
now if you are throwing a model in
tensorflow the chances are that you have
to use
a uh the sequential api which is like
the normal one
when you have layers uh or where you can
sorry what you have like a stack of
layers
layer one layer two layer three four
five six that's good
however in the functional api you need
to specify you need to draw the graph
between your layers so you have the
layers are like kind of laid down on a
table
and then you have to make the connection
between them without making
a cycle tensorflow does not like cycles
and here
you need to specify the input as well as
the outputs and for this new model
i want to use the same input as i have
in my previous model
so the input of my first sequential
model of my first
image classifier is going to be the same
one in this model
however the same is not about the output
for example if you remember from my
first sequential model
the output is the dense layer which
which gives me the label
jesse or james however in this case i
want the output of my functional model
to be the outputs plural with s
the outputs of my convolutional and my
pulling
layers meaning that the output is going
to be an array of length
six because i have three convolutional
layers and three max pooling layer
where oops oops i'm sorry about that so
the output is going to be
an array of lens fixed where each
entry is the outputs of my convolutional
and max pooling layers
and this output these are the these are
the activation
maps so after predicting i'm going to
have one
array of lens six where each entry is
the activation maps of each of the
layers now let's let me show this
quickly in code like
what what exactly i'm talking about
first i'm loading my first model
the normal object classifier i train in
tensorflow using the sequential api
right now i'm going to create one empty
list called output layers
then i'm going to iterate over the first
six layers
of my network
while pushing to this list the output of
the layer
again iterate over the first six layers
which are the convolutional mass pulling
and then i'm going to append to my list
the output of the layer
then i'm going to create my model using
tf.model
and using as input the input of my first
model
and the output the output of the
of that sorry and as output the output
of
my convolutional and max pooling layer
in terms of flow is the same process
first i'm loading the model
then i'm going to create one list called
output layers
and then i'm going to create my
activation model
cool so yeah the prediction output is
the activation mass of the six layers
however we need to copy deeper than that
because
these layers they have filters so when
i'm talking about the activation maps of
my layers i'm actually talking about the
activation maps or the filters
of my layers and for doing so
i need to create some several i need to
index more stuff here
for example i need to specify which
layer
i want to draw and which filter of this
layer
so for doing so in my web application i
built some kind of helper function
what i where where first i'm sending
the the complete set of activations
then i'm going to use the layer of the
index i want to draw
and then i'm going to use the filter i
want to draw
and you don't have to pay attention to
this i just want you to see the third
line
where you can see all the indexing i'm
doing so i'm indexing
the layer and then i'm going to select
the filter i want to draw
for doing so in in terms of flow is the
same thing
on the first line i'm getting the first
layer and on the second line i'm going
to specify which filter
i want to draw using filter number and
then
i'm going to show it on script so now
for the final app
this is how it looks like and here we
have the first part of my
of my application where i can see where
it is showing me the object detection
very similar to this thing we saw be
before we have one image we upload the
image we get the prediction output the
label
and the bounding box and now this is the
cool part the activation maps
now here i have the activation map
section of my first layer
so since i have six layers i actually
have six
group of this thing that you see here
one per layer
and under the label under the name of my
area which here is convolutional to the
layer activation i have a small slider
that i'm using to select the filter
i want to draw as a heat map and then
below that is there's the heat map
itself where i can see the output of my
filter and the activation
and here we have like the the values and
the highest the value
is it means the most important that part
of the image or that feature is to them
to the classification and the lowest the
value the least
important this part of the image is at
the time of making the
prediction now let's see a proper
example and here we have
jesse and now it's time to answer the
main question here
how is the network capable of doing this
what is the is the network looking at
and the answer is the hair
is anybody surprised is anyone surprised
i guess not because of course that's the
most common the most dominant feature of
jesse
the hair and that's exactly what i
wanted to solve so problem solved
super happy and here we have six
different activation maps
one per layer and just using one random
filter that i don't really remember
which one was it
and we can see that all of them the main
feature of the
image i mean of this activation map is
just jessie's hair
and also you're going to realize that as
we go down you know like uh
the first image corresponds to the first
layer second layer third layer blah blah
blah
and then you can see as we go down the
resolution gets slower and lower because
that's how it works
now for another example this one was
james and the
result is almost the same we have a lot
of focus on jane's hair
even including his beard on image number
five
but once again sometimes it fails
for example here this is the same image
as before and if you take a look at the
activations well
they're all over the place we have high
high values like
even in the background of the image
which is totally wrong
so and that was it now for the takeaways
and
i want to end this by saying that in my
opinion
right expandable ai is as important as
ai
itself and as we keep building and
deploying
artificial intelligence solutions
everywhere we need to keep in mind that
these tools as great and amazing as they
are they are not
it's not fully they are not fully easy
to understand
and we're making a lot of decisions
decisions that are
improving our lives so we should
actually be more careful you know we
should be
taker about exactly to know why the
model is doing
this so we should explain you know just
in case something happened and we need
to give an explanation to someone to
someone which could be your boss for
example
also i want to say that in my opinion
once again
a web application is a suitable platform
for a data product and
we don't see them quite quite often
normally we have
a python script python notebook and so
on
but i like working on the web because
you have the complete ecosystem that
javascript
has to offer so you have like buttons
library graph and whatnot
also i want to say that the
compatibility between tensorflow gs and
tensorflow is improving vastly
so which is passing day it is even
easier to convert one model to the other
also if you know one of the platforms
it's quite easy to use the other one
since their apis are very similar the
only thing you need to keep in mind is
just the
particularities of the language itself
last i want to say that in politically
speaking the networks are better than
ash
and why is that well because they look
at him broke as hair
and now i also want to repeat and say
that this was a very
very fun project so let's have you for
your time
it's been a pleasure to be here here you
can see several links
which the first one pointing to the
github repo and here you have all the
code including all the training set and
testing set
they have an article in case you want to
read the whole process
and there's also one demo and in the
demo if you need one
you need images but you can find them in
the github repos so
i hope you guys had an amazing time
hopefully
i mean i hope to see all your questions
regards
comments and whatnot and feel free to
contact me either here in the chat or on
twitter so thank you and happy pi data
bye